hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem kleinen mehr oder weniger
aufklärungs video kann man das nennen
und zwar ist er heute morgen irgendwie
um acht uhr morgens also die neue hero
folger untergekommen ich weiß nicht
warum die um 8 uhr morgens online gaben
die sollte eigentlich wie gewohnt um 14
uhr 30 nachmittags kommen
wie gesagt habe keine ahnung was youtube
sich da wieder zusammen gebeutelt hat in
deren topf der verschwörung gegen uns
alle weil mittlerweile alles schlechter
wird aber das ist ein ganz anderes thema
jedenfalls geht es heute in diesem
kurzen kleine info video um die aktion
die regel nicht bei zombie gemacht haben
und zwar haben wir uns daher ein paar
sachen genommen weil wir dachten das
sieht man sogar an der aufnahme dass wir
das das cerro nix haus sei und da wir
das ganze um leistung aufgenommen haben
und simon nochmals ok macht durch wenn
das der onyx hauses blabla blöd ist nur
dass da ein schild dran stand mit
zombies gruft oder so dass haben gegen
die beiden übersehen weil ich mich nur
auf die kisten fokussiert habe und auf
re wieder da schon in den kisten
ordentlich am rausnehmen war und
regiment her auch höhere das ist
rangnicks nicht anzuheizen dürfen da
wirklich da draußen
der materialmix aus dem spiel denn
lieber mit blabla können wir machen ja
okay da machen wir das einfach mal ein
sache ist jetzt nur dass zum base ich
dann halt gesagt also haye bei mir wurde
sache geklärt wieso das war ein haus
sorry leute zombie absolvent
missverständnis war es der scheiß egal
kurz mal die blablabla wir uns alle ganz
doll lieb herzlichen um die ganze welt
jedenfalls werden wir irgendwann mal mit
zombie aufnehmen und ihnen die sachen
zurück geben ich habe ihm auch gesagt er
kann sich einfach irgend welche sachen
bei mir nehmen die er braucht so als
kleine entschuldigung und das gleiche
wurde mir auch freigestellt von malte
und manuel von broken fans und zwar
haben die sich meint okubo jockey
ausgeliehen
was ich ja erst mal nicht so cool finde
wenn man sich einfach so sachen cloud
deswegen kann ich das bei zombie mir
tausend entschuldigt das ist unser leid
tut und so aber die haben mir jetzt
gesagt weil die sind irgendwie aus der
stadt ausgezogen oder so und können wir
dann das turbo nicht so ganz schnell
zurück bringen weil die auch vor
produziert haben unter anderem und
deswegen bringen wir das jobo einfach
zurück wenn sie wieder halt in der stadt
mal vorbeikommen oder so und dann stelle
ich mir das einfach wieder ab bei mir zu
hause also dann ist druck wieder bei mir
ich hoffe jockey geht's gut berlin
und dann darf ich mich während der
zwischenzeit wo die mir dann schoki
zurückbringt darf ich mich dann auch bei
denen an den kisten so ein bisschen
bedienen als ich hätte jetzt nicht alles
rausnehmen oder so ich werde mir doch
mal ein bisschen gold nehmen wenn ich
das dann mal brauchen oder ein bisschen
was zu essen wenn ich gerade nichts mehr
ab oder so also ich werde das jetzt
nicht grundsätzlich heftig da ausnutzen
ich hoffe nicht dass zombie das bei mir
macht jedenfalls sind wir alle cool
miteinander und da brauchte ich gar
keine sorgen machen weil jetzt bei mir
unter dem video wird jetzt mega vier rom
gesperrt
hier kommt lola blau also zombies da
ganz locker reagiert wir geben ihm die
sachen zurück sogar noch mehr und ist
auf jeden fall leid ich hoffe ihr könnt
das jetzt nachvollziehen
eigentlich sollte heute nur hero kommen
nicht dieses hin zu video hier weil ich
noch sehr viel zu tun habe
bezüglich universität et cetera
führerschein musiker nebenbei machen und
alles und ja meine lieben freunde noch
nicht sagen wann geht's weiter mit
heroin kommt mir die kommentare
schreiben was ihr in der zukunft in
dieser die nächsten tage noch so sehen
wollt ihr könnt mir ein paar challenge
accepted sachen schreiben vielleicht ein
paar minecraft facts dann werde ich mich
da mal wieder ein bisschen dran setzen
auf ccc sind natürlich immer schön gut
gesehen und dann würde ich sagen durch
das jetzt dieses video hier machen
musste weil es eigentlich klar ist dass
wir bei so was jetzt nicht sofort in
totalen streit geraten bei solchen
kleinigkeiten aber die community pegel
deshalb manchmal zu einem gewissen level
dann hoch wenn man dann auch mal
einschreiten muss man sagen muss nein es
war anders und ich hoffe ihr habt jetzt
verstanden und dann würde ich sagen
sehen uns morgen wieder